chavez et rachel legrain-trapani sont
devenus les meilleurs amis du monde
rumeur ou pas rumeurs piquer son mec
pardon alors effectivement c'est une
rumeur total 1 peuvent toujours pas se
saquer a invité de touche pas à mon
poste ce mardi miss france 2010 ne l'a
fait revenu sur les déclarations de
rachel et s'arrêtera chaîne tv2
notamment des choses là je fais une
parenthèse mais sur l'isf france en
disant qu'elle s'était pas très bien
entendu quand on a fait un dossier miss
france et sylvie tellier a confirmé ce
que tu avais dit aussi faut reconnaître
qu'en ce moment quand tu parles s'est
repris tu donnes des bonnes infos du
travail c'est très bien ma chérie je
t'adore regardez la vidéo sera pas
d'hyper solide que vaille manama chavez
la déteste regarde je pense en tout cas
qu'elle me déteste et c'est à cause de
toi n'ont qu'à me sers malika ménard
mais dit on se voit ce soir chez valve
mal à ma vie pourquoi il se passe
quelque chose
webhelp une soirée atépa invités banon
et c'est vrai cette histoire oui j'ai
pas invité mais en même temps quand on
se connaît pas plus que ça enfin
d'inviter des gens que tu connais pas
chez toi vous dire où précisément leur
tour de magnéto de même dans la bonté
l'émission tu as 3 2 1 on revient
vous savez vous êtes sur un plateau de
télé aucune image des lampes à uv
donc voilà elle a confirmé elle dit
juste parce qu'elle te connais pas enfin
pas plus que ça oise et je sais qu'on
vous avez aussi a pas très longtemps
vous avez fait un petit peu de promo
ensemble oui non mais en fait on s'est
croisé plusieurs fois sur les bonnes
fées donc oui on se connaît et après
c'est vrai que en fait c'est une
institution nous depuis en fait depuis
moi ça fait 13 ans que j'ai été élue
miss france donc généralement tous les
ans on fait un dîner tout ensemble on
est c'est vrai on est comme vous dites
tout c'est quoi c'est parce que
valenciennes
il vient de mettre plus de pas de puiser
une famille nous seront streamés
jusqu'au village de coviva 53 donc avec
alexandra rosenfeld
on a été très très amis donc ça commence
dans les années 90 à 2007
d'accord et ensuite il ya eu valérie
pareil on était très amis et ensuite on
a continué ce2 de combien odile et demi
sans veron notre combi environ chaque
fois bah ça dépend dû rentrer les
personnes qui sont là on est on fait des
dîners des soins on est dix l'accord
très bien et donc la wii est donc que
tous les ans on se retrouve on essaye
pour que justement on créé ce lien et
c'est donc voilà donc deux ordres
comme dans toutes les familles même si
on connaît pas pour sûr j'ai compris et
la banda ma monde par par principe et
par respect après voilà elle veut pas
m'inviter ya jusqu'à cette année c'est
donc elle qui l'a fait et elle tape a
invité oui voilà même et de la jalousie
un nom moi franchement ça m'est
complètement égal et s'accapare c'est
juste que ben voila moi je sais que on
est très proches les unes des autres et
samo same avait fait un peu mal au coeur
le fait que voilà toutes les miss
walhalla oui mais tu es libéralisme qui
depuis travaille plus la télé voilà on
verra ce qu'elle frapperait rendent à
rendez-vous au tas de sable c'est c'est
allah c'est à la fin de la foire qu'on à
la fin du bal qu'on paie pas
mais sur des congrès j'étais la seule de
toutes les miss a peut être invités où
il a une autre qui était oui d'aidé en
des dernières piques et la sole
s'étaient vus en fait le mot on est en
fin de l'après midi pour les bonnes fées
c'est dire quelqu'un elle connaît toutes
les autres sauf toi oui ils ont qu'a
fait exprès avec ses bas merci bien plus
salée malhonnête
quand même parce que j'aime bien ce
genre de choses moi j'aime bien les gens
un peu garce est tout sauf que en tout
cas si tu fais un bon avocat
je vous aime bien mais les mauvaises
personnes